[Música]
após você ter vivido experiências de
vida no dia de hoje
em relação à sua carreira eu pergunto
aonde você quer chegar e objetivos
você pretende alcançar em cinco anos dez
anos em 20 anos
o mais importante que é que você está
fazendo
hoje para chegar lá é muito importante
que você assuma o protagonismo da sua
carreira
traçando um paralelo do que as empresas
fazem alcançado sucesso os seus projetos
como organizam como planejam será que é
possível a gente em nossas carreiras
utilizar técnicas e métodos das empresas
para obter o mesmo êxito apesar das
mudanças muito grandes que estão
acontecendo impactos das novas
tecnologias nas profissões de hoje e das
profissões do futuro
eu sou um adepto de que os objetivos de
carreira de longo prazo precisa ser
planejado sopa da igas ia carioca ainda
torcedor do fluminense e que considera
um agente de transformação
organizacional com o propósito de tornar
a tecnologia da informação um pilar
estratégico das empresas e vou
compartilhar minhas experiências
profissionais e pessoais que me levaram
a ter sucesso na minha vida e no meu
trabalho
ao longo da minha actividade
profissional trabalhei em três empresas
duas multinacionais duas no rio de
janeiro e os meus últimos 20 anos foram
dedicados à estratégia de evolução e
crescimento de uma multinacional
brasileira com sede em jaraguá do sul em
santa catarina
sempre atuei como agente de
transformação em tecnologia da
informação e como podemos chamar de
forma simplificada e ao longo da minha
vida aprendi métodos e metodologias para
implantar projetos mudanças ao longo de
todo a empresa que eu trabalhei mas tem
uma especial que eu sempre utilizei e
ainda utilizo é o que eu chamo de freio
working de transformação organizacional
ele é uma adaptação que eu fiz de um
modelo que aprendi quando trabalhei uma
consultoria
vou fazer uma breve descrição desse
modelo
primeiro no topo nós temos a visão a
visão é o norte né
é o estado futuro que se quer alcançar
em seguida estabelece a estratégia para
alcançar essa visão
aí vem quais são os recursos necessários
à implantação estratégia no caso de um
projeto de tiê
é importante trabalhar em conjunto
processos pessoas e tecnologia
aí vem a organização pra que a gente use
de forma mais eficaz os recursos
necessários para realizar a estratégia o
fio resultados resultados é o que a
empresa espera ganhos e benefícios que a
empresa espera alcançar ao final dessa
implantação
dependendo do escopo dependendo da
abrangência além de você traz a visão
até o resultado também é muito
importante você trabalhar o que está no
entorno aqui cultura organizacional em
parte da empresa
lá os negócios e também clientes e
fornecedores
mas hoje aqui eu não vim falar sobre
transformação organizacional
quando me preparando pra falar aqui no
tek jaraguá do sul
eu percebi que de forma consciente ou
inconsciente
eu também apliquei esse framework de
transformação organizacional ao longo de
toda a minha carreira hoje aqui tenho a
pretensão de ajudar você avaliar sua
carreira com o mesmo olhar de quem
gerencia uma grande transformação para
que faça o planejamento necessário para
executar seus planos seus sonhos e seus
objetivos futuro principalmente na vida
profissional e vou fazer uma viagem com
vocês
é desse tremor que inclusive e função da
minha preparação do feder do detex eu
alterei para agora framework de plano
estratégico de carreira no início
pessoal no topo
nós temos a visão a minha visão foi
estabelecido ainda na infância
meus pais eram comerciantes tínhamos uma
vida confortável
nossa família é muito bem mas veio uma
derrocada e odor tudo
apesar da educação e dos valores que
recebi dos meus pais
eu tomei uma decisão eu não quero ser
patrão
eu quero ser empregado mas eu vou
trabalhar o meu melhor para que eu
consiga atingir universa qo mais alto
quer ver as competências me leve
o que é ser melhor pessoal é muito
importante que eu digo pra vocês que eu
nunca me comparo nunca me comparei com
colegas de trabalho nunca me comparei
com o colega de profissão o meu melhor
com a minha motivação com a minha
energia chegar aonde a minhas
competências me leve estratégia ao longo
da minha carreira estabelecer premissas
de atuação que me ajudaram bastante em
todas as empresas que eu passei
primeiro eu sempre queria ver as
atribuições e responsabilidades de dois
cargos a nível acima do do meu cargo
atual
e eu procurava de ver e adquirir
conhecimentos com relação aos carros
segundo todo início de ano eu definia os
meus objetivos de aquisição de
conhecimento e novas experiências e eu
controlava o planejado com realizado o
terceiro tem como premissa que a minha
ausência não seja percebida
então sempre orientei meus gestores
minhas equipes de trabalho para a
autogestão para tomada de decisão
autônoma mesmo na minha ausência
4 quando o presente sempre procuro gerar
um diferencial principalmente
estabelecendo as equações desafio
fazendo o que eles enxergam além do
normal
buscando sempre o resultado acima
daquilo que a empresa a princípio
enxergava daquele projecto próximo
recurso da realidade recurso na carreira
ela tem a ver com o conhecimento tem a
ver com habilidades e tem a ver com
formação mas eu sempre fui orientado a
estudual e que considerava autodidata e
numa determinada etapa da minha vida
obter o diploma superior
eu estudei no colégio naval escola
militar da marinha regra do rei do rio
de janeiro 16 anos
fiz a minha primeira desistência minha
primeira escolha
decidi que não ia seguir na carreira
militar mas a base de conhecimento que
obtive no colégio foi excelente e
comecei na vida escolar
há um momento de desafios existência as
escolhas e na escolha
apesar de ter iniciado três cursos
diferentes engenharia matemática e
administração
eu iniciava e desistiram ou porque o
curso naquele momento não trazia para
mim o que eu esperava ou por alguma
restrição ou dificuldade que eu estava
vivendo aquele momento
mas aos 36 anos pessoal
quase que eu coloque em risco a minha
visão de alcançar o mais alto nível que
eu pudesse ser o uma falha minha
essa questão de valorizar o diploma de
nível superior
eu tive a oportunidade foi indicado para
ser o meu primeiro cargo de gerente da
multinacional que trabalhava já era
coordenador
mas só que era obrigatório o curso
superior
foi então que mudei a estratégia garante
o diretor que focaria objetivo agora da
minha formação acadêmica
decidi fazer administração antes mesmo
de terminar o curso foi promovido e a
partir daí comecei a valorizar a minha
formação acadêmica
fiz diversos cursos de pós graduação e
também consegui o título de mestre em
engenharia de produção
a direção organização é como eu utilizei
meus conhecimentos
minhas habilidades e as atitudes ao
longo de toda as empresas que eu
trabalhei e resultado resultado pessoal
eu consigo dividir a minha e da minha
carreira em três fases a primeira
empresa
ela foi responsável pela minha minha
fase técnica de formação técnica entre
estagiário sair analista de sistemas
sênior a segunda empresa foi responsável
pela minha formação enquanto gestor
eu entrei coordenador e sair gerente é a
minha terceira empresa foi responsável
pela minha carreira executiva entre
gerente sair diretor
então o pessoal cheguei lá a sofrer o
primeiro funcionário a receber o carro
de diretor estatutário de tecnologia da
informação de uma grande multinacional
brasileira aqui de jaraguá do sul
empresa que eu tenho muito orgulho de
ter trabalhado empresa que é um celeiro
de talentos em todos os dizer a que eu
considero um verdadeiro uma verdadeira
escola de excelência de gestão
empresarial tal os desafios que a gente
vive no dia a dia muito feliz de ter
chegado lá
nessa empresa mas a vida pessoal pra mim
sucesso e felicidade
andam muito juntos e não é um ponto de
chegada
ele é uma jornada é uma estranha a
trajetória e mesmo
muito feliz na empresa uma carreira
sólida e muito bem estabelecida para
buscar um novo propósito de vida decidi
antecipar a aposentadoria seria em
dezembro do ano que vem e agora definir
um novo desafio uma nova visão para mim
criar uma empresa de consultoria
estratégica e agora a minha visão é ser
o melhor empresário melhor consultor
estratégico é minhas competências me
leve só para fazer um panorama é agora
que eu criei foi o que de plano
estratégico de carreira tão importante
quanto estabelecer a visão e os
resultados é você olhar também os
aspectos pessoais o aspecto de família
o aspecto sociedade eo mercado de
trabalho que se pretende atuar
e além disso é de suma importância que
você realmente planeja e acompanhe o teu
planejamento e agora pessoal de forma
consciente
eu estou utilizando esse fervor para
planejar os meus próximos passos naquilo
que são é o meu objetivo de vida para os
próximos anos
e você
em seu plano é estabelecer sua visão
estabelecer sua estratégia
quais são os recursos necessários
como você vai se organizar e que
resultados você espera alcançar pessoal
espero que essa minha fala consiga tocar
e motivar você a planejar e senti a
necessidade de planejar seus objetivos e
se autoanalisar como uma empresa
por isso convido que você olhe em
retrospecto para sua vida e definir o
que fará daqui pra frente
não tenha pressa é a forma
não tenha medo de desistir desistir é
fazer escolhas
as minhas escolhas que fizeram com que
eu estivesse hoje frente a frente com
vocês
indo para a conclusão pessoal eu
pergunto o que você quer ser o que você
tem de objetivos para os próximos anos
para o futuro o mais importante o que
você está fazendo hoje
para chegar lá
defende visão até resultados da
realidade
o pessoal de coração que este momento
seja muito importante para vocês e que
sirva de inspiração para que cada um de
vocês
pense no seu novo amanhã lá desde o seu
novo amanhã e o mais importante ainda
realize seu novo aí
mas preste bem atenção à neide se o seu
futuro mas a incerteza do amanhã escolha
ser feliz hoje
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]